ladies and gentlemen boys and girls to
YouTube this is where the video happened
to switch ATT okay that's wonderful well
I got my first AT&T bill where the magic
was made right here the grease Milka in
front of this outlet in a box
[Music]
the solids been seen many many times
online approximately a million has a lot
of you
[Music]
everybody say hi it's my friendly outlet
they had a crazy milk of coffee company
that's how my my garments does it when
you put it in the GPS I can't see
anything right now let me let me put my
eyes back on oh there you are
[Music]
so I have an iPhone you know we all know
300 pages the streetlight start to fade
away
I see the white onion when you're asleep
[Music]